[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember Little Pony I used to wonder
what friendship could be my little turn
this video into another brony message
board now set up if you haven't noticed
that them roped into babysitting this
week and all because I owe a certain
someone a certain favor hey mister sabab
he almost done almost I'm finalizing the
plans for my next movie deal it's white
gift for trading my soul for a Goods odd
impression so what I kids normally do
they make tofu or something well you
could read me a story yeah okay this
one's a classic we looked then we saw
him step in on the mat we looked and we
saw him The Cat in the Hat wait why did
he look like a cat because he's a cat no
that's not what he looks like he's
supposed to be scary and weird and
constantly out of breath what and why is
it all in rhyme because it's dr. Seuss
everything he does is in rhyme no he's
only supposed to rhyme once in a while
and where's all the subplots and in
jokes and advertisements and forced
morals and penis innuendos oh fuck are
you talking about
[Music]
this isn't dr. Seuss it's not even close
it's evil corporate pandering with
freaky imagery that's promoting
everything that's wrong with humanity
this was next to son the mask wasn't it
[Music]
who would think in any way this innocent
little story would be connected to this
big-budget sellout oh oh no it's Peters
soulless yeah the Hollywood executive
who bought all the film rights to dr.
Seuss calling the ass with the cash I
see you're young and impressionable too
so I have a GG load of crunk here for
you
with modern jokes adult jokes and poop
jokes galore breakfast his kids won't
get who could ask for more it's totally
the boss and with the in-crowd
is there any pwnage this funky
disallowed stop it's not trying to sound
cool is my his Ian and Izzy look you
clearly have no idea how people talk and
you clearly have no idea what made dr.
Seuss a great author whatever do you
mean all right if I can take this chance
to enlighten you on how dr. Seuss is
being butchered nowadays maybe some good
can come with us will you say kiddo you
ready to take a trip into some awkward
humor
with Mike Myers let us journey into dr.
Seuss's The Cat in the Hat it's
important to note that the director of
this movie is beau Welch a world famous
production desire on a lot of Tim Burton
movies and barry sonnenfeld productions
I say this because clearly he's much
better at directing the set than he is
at directing his actors though as you
can see even that can get a little
extreme
I feel come at the beginning of a
Doublemint gum commercial
we see the mother works at a hand
sanitizer Factory also known as Howie
Mandel's candy store where we see one of
the many reoccurring themes and current
dr. Seuss productions weeks of bourbon
commentary tonight is our bimonthly meet
and greet party tonight's host is Joan
Walden Joan if your house is as messy as
last time so what level of not caring
are our actors at in this movie let's
see we passed Dennis Hopper from Super
Mario Brothers Pass Russell Crowe from
anything he's in Annie were right up to
Jeremy Irons from Dungeons & Dragons
my kids will be on their best behavior
we can see her two kids at home played
by Spencer Breslin and Dakota Fanning
who's best known for playing a
strange-looking lifeless puppet oh and
Coraline they spend most of their time
setting up their story arcs that will
obviously be changed by our thankfully
neutered protagonist he's a message from
maker she's a control freak and neither
of them put any emotion into their
performances this was all Sally's full I
tried to tell him mom why don't you go
upstairs this is just as much my father
thought they always wind it on their
feet I've got this one in my list this
was my fault
Stephen Hawking's voice box emotes more
than them why do I always have to do the
opposite of what I'm supposed to God
with some fucking emotion into it and
speaking of actors who just gave up Alec
Baldwin plays the evil neighbor who
wants to marry the mother and send her
son Conrad off to military school why I
don't know something has to account for
this uncomfortably force conflict here
though maybe if you just behave I
wouldn't have to consider military
school I wish I could trust you I was
trying a different mom well sometimes I
wish the same thing
okay so listen here's one of my big
problems here if you're going to show
family dilemmas and conflicts try
actually showing it the kid and mothers
snapping at each other you can even call
it that it's so unemotional seems
needlessly mean and unjustified there's
little to no build up to such harshness
being delivered from both of them well
we need to add some extra morals why the
one the book is fine as well as unique
sometimes a little rule breaking is okay
as long as it never goes too far that's
a rare message for kids and suits
delivered it in a balanced way because
the kids were normal kids
here the boy is already out of control
and the girl is the other extreme so the
message is already getting confused well
we needed to change it around for the
longer running time
Polar Express kept the message focused
with the longer running time Mary
Poppins kept the message focused with a
longer running time why couldn't this oh
what good are those movies anyway they
don't even have pop cultural references
that and we knew Mike Myers would only
be funny for one more year we had to
cash in on him as quickly as possible
speaking of which yes it's just about
that time isn't it after a pre
shockingly offensive stereotype comes to
babysit they start watching TV you tell
them glide jump no more big government
okay movie that was like five racist
jokes at a time we're losing track about
what qualities were supposed to not like
about them am I supposed to hate how
they talk different or how they look
different as she falls asleep we finally
get the appearance of our geisha covered
in pubes Mike Myers
that could have gone better mr. critic
is that what happens when Pepe LePew
makes whoopee with Ronald McDonald yes
yes it is no what are we hiding from now
for those who don't remember there was a
time when Mike Myers ruled the fucking
world he was a hit on Saturday Night
Live grew a cult following with Austin
Powers resulting in a monster hit with
its sequel landed another big hit with
Shrek killed as a host of the MTV Movie
Awards and I'm just gonna say it he may
not have been bad funny what or at least
not as funny as we built him up to be he
had some good characters he had some
good bits and he seemed to have a
likeable personality but after a while
people start to catch on to the
repetition of his humor that without
proper support couldn't keep everybody
laughing for very long and nowhere is
that more painfully spotlighted than in
this flick look at this scene where he
has to keep you entertained for a good
solid minute just on his own why I'm the
captain there's no doubt about that
I'm a superfund difference feline who's
here to make sure that you are realize I
got nothing I'm not so good with the
rhyming not really no yeah the Cat in
the Hat the most famous dr. Seuss
character of all time is not good at
rhyming starting to see what I'm talking
about his shtick seems to be
acknowledging that what he's saying
isn't funny which at first is funny but
then you realize constantly
acknowledging what he's saying isn't
funny suddenly result in thinking what
he's saying isn't funny where did you
come from my place what do you think
on top of that he doesn't really have
much of a character I mean I guess it's
trying to be Bugs Bunny ish but he never
really seems to care about what his
motivation is or how to carry it out he
just seems more concerned about making
bad jokes him winking to the camera than
he does actually interacting with the
kids half the time he doesn't even look
them in the face oh but come on critic
he has this laugh okay that doesn't
create a three-dimensional character
what if he did it again doing it again
isn't gonna change anything about again
[Laughter]
please please
that having him laugh again and again
does not give him an identity
I mean he's not as good as what don't
make me say it
say what please don't what were you
going to say I can't what is it please
don't make me say it what is it he's not
as good as Jim Carrey in the Grinch shut
up it doesn't mean it was good but
Carrey had a clear character and
eccentric grump and his face was
expressive enough to work its way
through all that makeup Meyer seems to
have two expressions pedo smile and
happy I shit my pants on top of that
Carrie had enough energy to become one
with the costume he could work with it
to show how fully animated his body
could be with Myers it always looks like
he's restrained by it like he's fighting
against it every time he's done with a
take it looks like he's gonna pass out
on Dakota Fanning even the costume just
looks like a cheap cutout you stick your
face in to accept it's being worn by one
of the Wayans brothers from white chicks
I don't necessarily blame Myers for this
it's just it wasn't the right casting
and to be fair how could anyone make a
joke like this in a dr. Seuss movie work
who is this
that's my mom
awkward yeah really soulless a dick
innuendo joke
well that was Justin throwing a little
dirty humor for the adults why do you
need to insert dirty humor in a dr.
Seuss film well if you want the answer
and I know that you do here is I know
this one and analyst - hey how can you
keep going in and out of rhyming it's
pretty inconsistent notes are a lazy way
of connecting to the source material
oh I I mean artistically it seemed to
make the most sense
you see critic according to polls or so
we've been told when kids hear adult
jokes it makes them feel old they feel
more grown-up to be in on the gag once
seen in the trailer it's cash in the bag
the same goes for butt jokes in modern
slang - it makes the crowds think we're
on the same level as you we talked the
same lingo in reference pop culture yes
focus groups make us more profitable
vultures
but Sue's got popular because he wrote
what he wanted to see not what focus
groups want to see have you ever
considered the possibility that maybe
people don't know what's best for them
and by continually giving them the same
crap they'll never know what's different
so they'll just keep asking for the same
crap well the chart says I'm not asking
the chart I'm asking you
well the chart says you are everything
that's wrong with entertainment but the
chart says
that was funny dude off the chart
did you talk the judge the chart so the
camp whips out a device called the fun a
meter which you would think shows how
phenomenally annoying he is but instead
restates what we already knew you're a
control freak and you're a rural brick
that'll be $700 who's your insurance
carrier me remember the fish actually no
we don't remember because this is the
first time you've been introduced kind
of late in the game to bring this
character in out of nowhere isn't it
[Music]
I'll become a mine there was his cat I
knew back home where I was bred he never
listened to a single thing is my dad
said you know I sometimes wonder if this
is all just a really wacky episode of To
Catch a Predator
[Music]
no I got it I know what this is this is
one of those fake trailers before Tropic
Thunder the one that looks real but is
so goddamn stupid it couldn't possibly
exist except this one actually exists
and you should cry because of it this
filthy thing she was gonna wear that
tonight you ruined it honey
it was ruined when she bought it yeah
you know whenever I have too much hope
I'll just remember to play that scene to
remind me that all is lost these things
will not bite you they want to have fun
so without further ado meat thing to
ante
[Music]
what did Marge said some Mutai with
albertine nomen those are hideous what'd
it look like the dr. Seuss book all
right first of all when did you start
following anything from the dr. Seuss
book second what makes something cute in
a drawing doesn't necessarily make it
cute in real life in drawing you can get
away with leaving certain things out
like upper lips per say they would look
like wrinkles if you put them in a
drawing but in real life it looks
fucking scary threes and cindy-lou was
the only cute character in the grinch
was because she was the only one who was
allowed to have an upper lip everyone
else looks like a demon-possessed hungry
hungry hippo and these two look like the
shining girls if both of the clown gave
them Jager bombs but uh-oh the dog gets
away and they have to get it back dirty
ho
8 that's 8 times dr. Seuss world in his
grave
[Music]
oh so they finally hanged him that's
nice
[Music]
critic
[Applause]
you
[Music]
hello hello critic are you coming back
I don't know child it's just that we're
seen what can somebody say to that I
don't know I mean it doesn't make any
sense at all cat gets hit in the balls
he's in a dress and on this plane with
the unicorn I have nothing for it I have
no jokes at all have I lost my mind Eva
Lena could it be that I've lost my touch
and making fun of scenes like this
could it be that the Cat in the Hat has
broken me I don't know but my dad will
kill you if he knows that you left me
alone instead of babysitting yeah I
guess you're right
I'll be back soon
[Music]
so after that scene Baldwin chases after
them but they escaped through a kiosk
where a party is going on yeah that
that's never explained in fact it's
forgotten just as quickly as is
discovered and then make their way back
home here she is the super luxurious
omnidirectional watch image again o L o
W is so it's better than the last thing
we had super hydraulic instantaneous
transporter
oh you mean
[Music]
[Laughter]
9 that's 9 times dr. Seuss the world in
his grave
only to discover that the cat magic box
has been left open and is spreading
chaos everywhere but let's be really
honest it's just trying to look like one
of the Seuss attractions at Universal
Studios don't believe me they literally
say it Universal Studios yes you just
saw that he literally directly
advertised to you Universal Studios I
don't think the entire running time of
The Wizard is as big a sellout as that
mere couple of seconds of Mike Myers
winking in fact I think every dr. Seuss
movie can be summed up in that one
gesture painfully obvious references
just totally unneeded adult jokes too
appealing desperately to the lowest
common denominator the same way Michael
Bay appeals to penises and Stephenie
Meyer appeals to vaginas in fact why
don't we just make this the new dr.
Seuss logo dr. Seuss we've gotten to
have so they find the crane and finally
close it all's awful Bad ends awful but
wait the place is still a mess you need
to get out but I thought you took want
to have fun today look around Kat you
were right it's fun count fun but you
have to know how and you don't know when
enough is enough please Oh finally the
only justified moment in this film I
just wish it happened an hour and a half
ago
[Music]
but if you know the story oh let's face
it doesn't matter if you do they follow
it so rarely but Kent comes in and fixes
everything and it wouldn't be a shitty
dr. Seuss movie if we didn't have a
shitty pop song for the soundtrack
and you're not gonna believe it but they
literally reference that selling point
to we even managed to work in an
up-tempo pop tune for the soundtrack
that's important Oprah god save solace
why are you being so obvious with how
evil you are well it's hip writing fat
number one if you say you're doing
something painful and stupid it's
immediately no longer painful and stupid
oh I see
critic I'm gonna hit you oh you can't
scream it's no longer painful and stupid
yes it is home / yes shop even with its
dumbest ending of mom happily returning
Baldwin being dumped and a party going
great but by having grown-up humor we
make it more adult by modernizing the
dialogue we make it more timeless and by
changing the source material we show how
much we want to make it even better no
every single thing you said you got
backwards by having grown-up humor you
make it more childish by modernizing the
dialogue you make it more dated and by
changing the source material you show
how much you don't respect what's
already perfect I'm not gonna act like
everything Seuss wrote was a masterpiece
but when he got it right he got it right
they don't need to be updated they don't
need to be fixed they don't even really
need to have movies made about them but
if you're going to do it the very least
you can do is understand the source
material well of course I understand the
source material they're just simple kids
books no they're not just simple kids
books there's stories that we are
continuing to read even today they're
stories that we remember years later
even when other stories fade from our
memory their stories we will never
forget and for good reason their stories
that helped shape our childhoods through
well thought out writing imaginative
drawings and endearing morals and the
idea of this shaping somebody's
childhood the fact that it even has the
same name just makes me sick to my
stomach
maybe these simple kids books a far more
adult than you give them credit for and
I guarantee that will show when years
later both children and adults will
still be reading these simple kids books
well pandering bullshit like this
disappears out of people's consciousness
also for good reason good heart doesn't
come from focus groups and statistics it
comes from people who share how they see
things in their own unique way Craig I
think I liked your book better than I
like the movie so do i kiddo so do I
know
no you're wrong you're all wrong I'm
going to show you all the Seuss movies I
tell you appreciate that great sweet dog
bye kissing no more nears our home with
anime references
somebody mister daddy how's my little
hey I know you
you're that executive that sold a soul
to make those horrible dr. Seuss movies
what oh yeah I rigged it so that each of
them would be a hit no person in their
logical mind would willingly go see that
shit that almost rhymes is that true
it's simply not true
and now it's time to return the favor
hey I know it's not my place or anything
but could I throw in a suggestion
torture sure what you want me to do what
with the fork buddy I like the way you
think oh well he gave me a lot to work
come my little little spawn enjoy that
book huh maybe there's some hope after
all I'm the Nostalgia Critic I remember
[Music]
[Applause]
you